it's not often discussed we like to put
on a sunny facade but behind closed
doors many of us go in for one of the
most tragic comic behaviors of
relationships sulking assault typically
starts over a disappointment
most often over an objectively rather
small matter
Marsden dust mill our day was Christine
forgot to notice Lars new haircut
worried wasn't paying chung-ho enough
attention at the party but what follows
isn't an argument it's an eerie silence
a domestic Cold War where inquiries as
to what's wrong I met with by one
resolute stony word what is a soap it's
made up of two things disappointment and
a deep-seated refusal to explain what
the disappointment is about why don't we
tell our lovers what's upsetting us
after all we explain so many things to
so many people in the course of our
lives we don't explain because of a
peculiar assumption about the nature of
love even people who are very good with
words might not when they were the lover
be in the mood to explain very much
where does this commitment to silence
come from it begins when we first learn
about love when we were tiny we couldn't
under need to make our intentions known
directly to those who loved us best they
knew what we wanted to eat just like
that they made sure we were comfortable
they took the trouble to guess what we
wanted this gave us a template but a
deeply unhelpful one about what adult
love might be like in the early days of
a new relationship there are some
blissful moments when two people
understand each other without needing to
say very much they magically agree on
things they sense a connection unlike
any other
but this is ultimately very misleading
in truth all of us are as adults
bafflingly complicated to expect someone
to understand us long term without us
having to explain is equivalent to
expecting someone to work out how
nuclear fission works simply by looking
at the outside of a power station for
others not to understand us without
explanation is no sign there even just
that they're human before retreating
into a sulk we should always do our
partners the honor of a small seminar
part of love means accepting the need to
teach others in kind and patient ways
about who we are at the same time when
we unwittingly unleash a song we should
realize that the soul cares being
strange and silent not because they're
mean but because at heart they're scared
they may be big and competent in many
areas yet inside they must be feeling
like a defenseless baby in the hands of
someone who seems not to know how to
look after them the greatest gift we can
give our lovers our explanations as calm
as we can make them using lots of words
about what we're truly like in all our
madness complexity and strangeness